اين يمكن ان اتوقع ان تكون تلك المفاوضات
ومن سيقودها او من سيرعاها
انا على ثقه بانه في كل الاحوال ستكون
هناك مفاوضات وانا ايضا مستمر بالاقتناع
بان دول شرق اوسطيه على الارجح ستشرف
وتلعب دورا رئيسيا فيها مثلما لعبت
السعوديه دورا في تبادل السجناء او تركيا
ناهيك انني ارجح ان تحتضنها انقره مثلا
خاصه ان تركيا هي من ترعى مبادره البحر
الاسود للحبوب كل ذلك يعزز قناعتي باننا
سنرى مفاوضات بنهايه العام وما اعلمه وهو
ينطوي على شيء من الرعب هو ان الرئيسيين
بوتيننسكي مقتنعان بان الحرب ستستمر الى
ان يتم حل مسالتين اثنتين
اولهما هو توقف الدول عن دعمهم بان هناك
دولا تدعم اوكرانيا ولكنها في نفس الوقت
تضخ الاموال في الاقتصاد الروسي مقابل
صادرات محدده وثانيا حتى يبلغ عدد القتلى
مستوى يتطلب توقف الحرب ومن المحتمل ان
يكون هناك رقم في دماغ غير الرئيسين
50 الف ومليون قتيل نحن لا نعرف هذا الرقم
لكن عندما يبلغ احدهما هذا الرقم ساعتها
سنرى الحربه تتوقف